well nick i can tell you there is still
a significant police presence at this uh
housing estate in kophili
they are carrying out or continuing to
carry out their inquiries but extremely
tragic it has traumatized this small
close-knit community we've had a
statement from the police in the last
hour or so this is from superintendent
mark hobra he said my condolences and
thoughts are with jack's family friends
school friends and everyone affected by
this within the community
we can confirm that the attack did not
happen in the house owned by jack's
family but inside another property on a
nearby street and this is
the street where the attack took place a
house down there you can see the police
car
in the background but people here have
been describing what happened yesterday
afternoon it's my understanding that
jack liss and a friend from school went
into the house down there where the
friend lived
there was no one else present at the
time except the dog we understand that
dog was being looked after they were
looking after it for a family friend
uh the the friends then ran out of the
house jack was being attacked and tried
to get a neighbor a few doors down to
come and help but i spoke to that
neighbor who told me by the time he got
there
the youngster had already been killed by
the dog now the police arrived here
we're told by neighbours
extremely quickly but there was a great
deal of distress and commotion people
here described uh what happened uh in
the moments afterwards this is what they
had to say
all we seen was like um children
screaming obviously there was children
screaming everybody was out in the
street we just seen um
there was a lot of um police cars and
ambulances it's just because it's a
child
and you just feel yeah
obviously it's like it's a close
community as such so when a child is
involved it's already happening
it's literally heartbreaking just can't
get over it
well this is the heart you know um
obviously we've been good with the
police you know looking after them and
and then back and forth my god wants to
jump over you know and there's a bit of
a tragic bonus it has affected us
and of course at the center of this
there is a family now grieving the loss
of their child
uh we've heard from uh jack's mother in
a facebook post uh the family are
appealing for privacy at this very
difficult time but his mother emma
whitfield has written with so much
heartbreak and before close friends and
family see his name in the news i have
to announce our beautiful uh boy jack
was taken so tragically yesterday we
love you so much
our sweet sweet boy
now in the last half an hour scene of
crime officers have been going into the
house they're carrying out forensic
examinations trying to piece together
exactly what happened we are expecting
more from the police in the next couple
of hours